hi hey how are you so far so good
yeah what is life like for you right now
in quarantine is it just you and the
bird it's just me the bird a couple of
homies a girl I will say like I'm
blessed enough that my business in my
life doesn't necessarily rely on me
leaving my house yeah and I was I was
insane before quarantine started so it's
impossible for me to go to go insane
like I was already there okay who's this
girl quarantine II with you you know you
threw it out there hi this is that
pretty early on huh
I mean we could wait and come back to
that yesterday
you want to wait just get back okay okay
um well then let's talk about valley
girl
[Music]
I first have to know did you learn to
sing for this like there's not a whole
lot of you singing but there is a line I
have one line I have one line and they
they maybe do it probably 50 times like
so it was it was it was hard it was I
think after I did my one line they're
like okay well pop will probably keep
his limit there no more singing for him
the pitch that they wanted me the hit
was not in my phone I was lucky enough
to be surrounded by a cast who like
actually has musical talent like it
could all of them could have been
singers and so they carried the song
more than I did yeah well I mean it's
fun to watch that did you have you like
gotten the acting bug now like do you
want to do more I do I do yeah I uh so
when I first came out to Hollywood I
wanted to be an actor that's what that
would that was my goal and then this
internet stuff kind of took over my life
and it is fun because you can literally
control everything which is nice and
with Hollywood it's a bit of a hurry up
and wait process you have to trust the
people around you I got trust issues I
had a lot of projects going wrong I had
a lot of projects go right but
traditional Hollywood is a bit more
formulaic than this chaotic vlog life
that I'm currently living in and I I go
back and forth between which I like but
I'm definitely gonna be doing more
acting soon I got it I got it I got
actually got a script that I wrote with
my roommate that we're going well you
wrote a script yeah well we wrote the
outline for the script pitched writers
and then selected writers to write a
full-on script that's awesome what is it
about it's about uh it's with my troupe
my roommate and best friend Evan eken
Rohtak a dwarf Mamba and like I would I
would go as far to say is I like I
truthfully believe that we are the best
physical comedy duo online and he's
talented as all get-out so us and the
internet people like us so I figured why
not adapted to a movie we're gonna have
a bidding war we're finishing up the
scriptable one more pass and we'll be
good to go and start pitching it and
then I think people are just hungry for
content now so hopefully these big
networks these platforms
Coughlin's some packs well going back to
valley girl how fun was it to wear those
outfits to get your hair done like that
every day though that's a great question
going to set was awesome I loved all the
cast I love dressing up and pretending I
was in the 80s like my parents even the
the songs it was like I loved music from
the 80s
I think the movie ends really really
strong I actually like someone emotional
towards the end maybe because I was
there on set and the movie has so much
like weight in real life for me yeah but
yeah it was amazing the one bad thing I
don't know if you notice my character
has a mullet Mickey Bowen has a mullet
and I also had a mother in real life so
it was all fun and games until I left
set to go back to the real world
anything
what 2018 and I'm walking around with a
mullet hanging down on my shoulders they
also told me there before the film
started this is bad this is really
unprofessional
she's like the director Rachel she's
like hey you know Mickey is a he's a
jock in high school he's a tennis player
and you're a little bulky right now
could you lose said 10 to 20 pounds for
us I go Rachel no problem I could lose
as much weighs you need and I didn't
lose anyway just so I am a very thick
high school tennis player did you try to
lose 10 to 20 pounds and I just didn't
go I think it I did I did try for like a
day and then I was like this is tough
did you see the original movie from 1983
with Nicolas Cage to sort of study were
you familiar with it I saw half of it
yeah I wanted to do like a little bit of
backstory but I realized it they aren't
that relate like stuff
the premise is somewhat similar right
but ours is a musical like full-on
musical what do you think fans are gonna
think of it being a musical if they were
fans of the original do you think
they're gonna like it do you think
they're gonna be like what it's tough
question because if you're a fan of the
original movie it most likely means your
ages 45 plus I would assume they'd like
a refreshing change of pace but
sometimes if you see something you love
the first time someone changes it you
know yeah nothing about it but well I
don't know I know I know I know the the
movie that was made and intended for a
younger audience that those people will
love it I want to get a little bit
personal with you because you and Chloe
Bennet who is your co-star in this movie
did dates for a little bit
now that some time has passed does this
movie sort of bring up any old feel
wrote this movie because it reminds you
of that time no no it doesn't you know
it's a good question and and it's it's
an inevitable thought obviously the yeah
cuz Chloe and I got close on set and had
a relationship thereafter and that girl
changed my life like I have so much love
for her I have so much love for Chloe
and I'm I'm so blessed that I got to do
that movie and spent and spend time with
her and and reap the benefits of just
being in her presence but we are on good
terms amicable platonic friendly and we
both just appreciate each other as
humans so no no no old old like romantic
feelings whatever but it was a very um
you know it's nostalgic watching back
this this time of my life where I was
going through so many changes both both
personally and publicly and she played a
monumental role in that and so yeah yeah
well I mean you said she changed your
life
those are some big at the bold statement
how how did she change your life she's I
I never had a mentor or someone to point
me in the right direction when I was
making bad decisions which at that time
my life was a lie and she in many ways
became a light for me in a time where I
did not have one and and I I move
forward I carry on today in my life with
values that she's instilled in me that I
I wouldn't gone from anywhere else or
haven't as far and yeah is like she's
just she's the the the principles in way
in the way she lives her life in the way
she thinks about people and her her
empathetic nature was was was contagious
to me in many ways like you learned you
learn from the people you hang out with
many of time with and she's definitely
one of the most impactful people that
I've ever had pleasure of coming across
in my life I've like one of the nicest
thing that anybody's ever said about
anybody yeah did you know the girls are
gem she she does
I'm moving on you do kind of play this
jock in the movie you play mickey hey
mickey your spine is basically your song
in this movie how would you describe him
like is he a jerk does he have good
qualities too mom
Mickey's he's ignorant he's ignorant
button he's got good intentions his
delivery
hey this is actually just like me a real
life his delivery sometimes needs a
little bit of work he's a fun-loving
ignorant immature kid I don't want to
like spoil anything hmm but hopefully
people will watch this after the fact
and we sort of get a life update from
where all the characters are and your
character submits himself to be on The
Bachelor every year which I thought was
freaking hilarious yep have you ever
thought about ever going on The Bachelor
in real life great question so yes I
have thought about going on it
here's my news why it'll never work ever
ah let's be honest - not voting the ho
that I could not take any of that
serious at all this it that is the most
yo yo yo I like skimmed across an
episode one day I was like what is what
is this show just like people knowingly
insert themselves in a scenario where
they really think they're gonna fall in
love with 12 cameras pointing at them
and miked up all the time well while the
person you're trying to fall in love
with is dating 12 other people how does
this make any sense I'm on I'm on I'd
like to consider myself a level-headed
semi intelligent young man I'd be
sitting there with wow this is just this
is not right this is not right and I
think the show works because everyone
there is really trying to fall in love
it's genuine authentic right that could
not gonna do it you did tell me on the
topic of love the last time I talked to
you that you had made a list what you
wanted and oh my god I did tell you that
with confidence intelligence opinionated
empathetic self-aware active listener
sexual deviant she got me a sexual
deviant tell me you do you don't want
your wife to be a 7dv come on guy
talented worldly she's gotta have
foresight and she
to be insightful yeah and that you were
looking to settle down and you were
hanging out with Josie Canseco like a
few weeks after that so what happened
there is she the girl that staying with
you yeah it is her you walk me through
how this happens you all to me you
you're the one that told me all of it I
know but something I do is exploit the
doubt of my life and I don't know if I'm
ready to exploit that part of it just
yet okay well can i play you a message
from somebody oh yeah it's from your
brother actually oh okay
hey Logan it's me your brother hi me and
the rest of the world want to know are
you single who are you dating tell us I
know there's somebody I think yours this
is cool what do you want I can't I can't
I can neither confirm or deny you
already confirmed it he knows I don't
know what he's like how did you get him
to do that I just said will you tape a
message that I could frame and that's
what we chose to ask you I just want to
live my family nor my life but normal my
life but it's hard because I put
everything on camera so some things I
try I try just a little bit to keep to
myself yeah that's fair and one more
thing about it yes she does she check
off all the things on your list that you
gave
nope
no what girl that the list I described
is a unicorn and I realized this
relationships are about compromise
if you if you have a checklist and the
person that you're with checks off every
single box I mean good for you I envy
that person that is insane I think the
idea the idea is to get in a
relationship and grow with the person as
they develop traits that you're
attractive
yeah so while she definitely checks out
the majority for sure you know just like
me
we both got stuff to work on how'd you
meet her I think just like the crossing
of LA circles like it was like a Venn
diagram you know I'm over here she's
over here and then we were like this one
night yeah
is it serious serious it is very serious
it pretty serious all right I won't I
won't press you anymore cuz I know you
don't like talking about it but I'm
happy for you Thanks um when I spoke to
Jake he also jokingly but a little bit
seriously said his biggest regret is
being related to you because sometimes
he gets a bad rap I told her I totally
get it I totally get it
there was definitely a phase where like
I was I was becoming a problem for him
except now if anything I think it's the
opposite
I mean I am in a much different much
healthier state of mind which equates to
me being better off in my life yeah like
I will I will not there are no more mess
ups on coming from this side Jake is
still a young lad there were some crazy
things being a little reckless sometimes
I'm pretty positive I have more to worry
about now than he does
yeah but you know it just I think it's
important to make a distinction that
Jake is not Logan Logan is not Jake I do
feel like I think I told you this one
time I do feel like you've grown so much
like I feel like we've watched you sort
of yeah
mature and learn a lot um what is the
biggest takeaway or lesson that you've
learned and how do you feel about where
you're at right now
III am I'm I'm so happy uh-huh there is
so much momentum positive just really
good energy in my life and surrounded by
amazing people who are all really driven
passionate talented I think that's it
there there was a very large evolution
that the place that I I think about this
all the time
can just be attributed to youth and
growth it's so interesting because
creators and internet kids live this
life on camera and they're expected to
hold themselves to a certain standard
because a lot of people watch them yeah
when I started making content do you
think I signed up to be a role model I
didn't give up I did not care all I
wanted to do is make funny videos and
then all the sudden now there's a lot of
people watching me whoa I have a
responsibility I have a duty to be a
beacon of excellence in in positivity in
life while still being authentic to
myself so it's this it's this weird
balance where as you grow up you learn
what's right and you learn what's wrong
however it's in front of the entire
world and so I don't I don't think I
don't think mistakes and setbacks and
failures are attributed to use maybe as
much as they should be I've always I've
always also been a late bloomer like
I've always matured slower I was the I
was the last one to go through puberty
in my high school and yeah you know just
that's just been the course of my life
story
do you ever feel like you almost got
famous making videos too young like do
you wish this come later in life I don't
I don't you know I think I think ya know
I love the course of my life I yeah
everything everything kind of fell into
place I do want to ask you about tick
tock yeah I'm just curious what your
your take on tick-tock and the success
of it is I think it's awesome I think I
think it's um obviously a massive
massive platform and Internet is all
about crust and troughs ups and downs as
long as you stay going up your pathos
are like this you're good the trouble
and challenge for the tic-tock kids will
be how to transition how to translate
your tik-tok success or 15 million
followers which mean absolutely nothing
on YouTube I'm worried for 99% of them
they will they will they my guess is
fall and spiral into a deep dark pit of
depression because they have this
inflated sense of
inflated sense of significance I think
any like anyone can apply on tick-tock
that's the great thing about the
platform it's so democratized anyone can
make a viral tick-tock and get followers
that's what they got to learn and figure
out are you speaking from personal
experience like was it hard for you to
figure out like you saw the success was
it ever hard for you to feel like how do
I transition this like how do I go to
the next level was it ever scary did you
ever like feel depressed about what
quarter would happen the only time I was
like in a in a state of prolong sadness
was after Tokyo but that wasn't that was
that was that was a result of me as far
as my career growth and in feeling lost
because of that I I say that because yes
it does come from a place of experience
and I'm just worried that you know like
hatred you're Alex savage like how far
can how far can disease you know you're
something like can you make money off of
this can you make a life out of this
like I don't know yeah I I wouldn't know
but you figure it out tick tock is a
sprint this game is a marathon yeah and
you gotta get created you got to
navigate it wisely when you think about
what your marathon looks like like what
is the future of Logan Powell's life
look like so just my mom was a massive
massive game changer in my life
impulsive when I started this podcast I
didn't really know how to podcast I
really know how to do anything or 180
episodes deep and it's it's it's
murdering it and I am I'm confident I'll
be doing this probably for the rest of
my life I also will do a lot of
transitioning to Hollywood I'll be
writing stuff directing stuff producing
stuff and then starting businesses
clothing we're about to relaunch mavar
clothing may 22nd and then there's one
more thing oh yeah signing talent
teaching teaching teaching empowering
the up-and-coming to be the best that
they can be I think that's the that's
what makes that's what that's what
separates a good from the great
yeah if you hooking up empower the
people
of the upcoming generations when you
think about your podcast and 180
episodes is crazy is there anything that
you won't talk about on the podcast I
feel like your life it's a pretty much
an open book is there is there a line
there it's it's the one thing I I won't
get too detailed and is just like my
relationship stuff I've always been like
semi low-key full transparency if you
get if you're a woman and you get tied
up in my life like your life will never
be the same it will just not the
Association the things you see here the
things you experienced here being around
me the way my mind works like it's it
once you're involved in my life it is a
whirlwind it is a is it is a chaotic
monsoon of X Y Z and so on I'm hesitant
to involve the person that I'm spending
my time with as much as I do everything
else for the sake of them in their life
it's not like a conversation that you
have with that yeah for sure
I didn't I didn't realize it until my
last relationship where I was like wow
whoa this had serious repercussions yeah
yeah yeah looks like it's just you say
the name you say the name Logan Paul or
like Jay Paul and depending on what room
you're in
some people get like a shiver down their
spine you know like it like just that
sound of is at home oh those kids oh
whoa and I totally get it we've done
some really good questionable non good
life decisions and and I just want
people to be aware of what that what
they're getting into before they before
they get into it yeah no I
by the way like I said this ooh I mean a
completely different phase in my life
it's much easier to hop on the train
right now
and I really am becoming an adult I
think I like it
but you know there's like there's a lot
going Isis scary yeah
[Music]